foreign
[Music]
hello everyone my name is
I am an assistant professor in the
department of immunology and infectious
disease and the Howard John School of
Public Health and my lab studies evasion
microbiome and its effect on infectious
diseases and host immunity and I'm here
to tell you a little bit today about
that subject and really try and convince
you that there are some really exciting
basic biological questions that we don't
fully understand about this incredibly
unique community and that
investigating those questions has the
potential for immense impact on public
health
okay
so to begin with what do we mean by the
microgram so we are mucosal surfaces
which you can think of roughly as any
part of our body that is open to or
interacts with the environment and since
our body plan is very much a tube within
the tube the one of the largest surface
areas is really the intestinal tract and
all of these mucosal surfaces are
occupied by a complex ecosystem of
bacteria viruses and fungi and we call
this together the microbiome but really
our tools for studying these are
probably the most advanced in the case
of bacteria so a lot of sort of
microbiome can often refer to the
bacterial community and for the purposes
of this talk that's actually what I'll
be referring to but I just want you to
keep in mind that that's just one
component of this ecosystem and as we
get better tools I will be able to
investigate all of these interactions as
well
and so when you look at that each of
these mucosal sites really have their
own microbiome and probably the site
that we know the most about is the
intestinal tract and we know there's
this really large Complex Community of
bacterial species that's incredibly
diverse and this diversity is strongly
linked to human health
additionally this community really
varies between people it's influenced by
diet it's influenced by where you live
and and what you can probably say is
that your microbiome was more similar on
different days between yourself and your
household numbers but it's hard to draw
conclusions beyond that
the vaginal microbiome however looks
quite different and part of that is
let's say what does the microbiome look
like
so over here on the left we have a
wonderful picture taken by uh curly
natural Genie from UBC and what you see
here is a picture of what the colon of a
mouse looks like and what you see in
green is your mucus and red and orange
are your bacterial species and in blue
are eukaryotic cells and what you see
right away is this really nice
separation between your bacterial
community and the eukaryotic cells and
we know a lot about what happens when
that separation goes away or how these
bacteria might interact with your cells
but when we think about what this looks
like in the version we really have very
little idea so on the right you have
really a smear from vaginal lavage and
what you've seen here is a large
um pink epithelial cell that is shed by
the vaginal epithelia as it's a
stratified squamous epithelia so you
have the oil cells sort of being
extruded and shed and that's totally
sort of covered with these
um rock shaped bacteria but a
lactobacilli we don't really have an
idea of what the spatial structure of
this looks like or what this looks like
inside people but we do know a little
bit about what the bacteria look like
and in fact we've known this for a while
so what do we know about the bachelor
microbiome this was actually these Rod
shaped lactobacilli were first described
in 1899 as daughter-in specialists it
wasn't really until the 1930s that they
were identified to activity metabolic
activity tests as lactobacillus
acidophilus
um
and uh more specific species were
identified with the onset of sequencing
and PCR in 1980s and what's interesting
is that really you see these
lactobacilli in people across the world
so it does seem to be quite common and
consistent and sharp contrast with what
we see in the gut and the other
interesting aspect is that this is
hormonally driven so on the table below
is actually from that 1928 paper by Matt
Stanley Thomas where they
um uh took vaginal lavage from children
and found that you did not see lactobus
alive in the majority of those smears
and many many studies since then have
shown that your lactobus light dominance
in the vagina is really associated with
onset of Monarch so this is puberty
driven and hormonal driven back to our
community that again is very consistent
around the world
um it wasn't really until
um the late 2000s that
um people use the tools of 16s
sequencing to look at vaginal bacterial
communities and what they found was sort
of incredibly impressive and really
fascinating from a biological
perspective so this is sort of chakra's
groundbreaking study that first
identified
um what vaginal bacterial communities
might look like in women who
reproductive age in the US and I'll just
Orient you to this graph a little bit
um so this is for pretty standard 16s
sequencing so what you're seeing here is
that um in every vertical row you have a
simple individual
while in the horizontal rows across
you're seeing different species of
bacteria so what you'll see right away
if you're used to seeing these
um you know from the intestinal practice
this is much smaller Community you
really have not more than 30 species
identified and the colors in the graph
go from show you relative abundance so
as you reach red you're reaching close
to 100 abundance while yellow is closer
to one
um and so you can actually start to make
our patterns in here
um so for example let's take the one
that has the most diversity and the most
color so you see over here there's a
community of people that have
um very few lactobacillitis you don't
see a lot of colors up in the
um higher top part of the chart what you
do see is a lot of sort of pink and
dictating like relative abundance of
um a bunch of bacterial species that are
highlighted by the black fire and this
is probably the most diversity that you
would see these kind of communities
where you don't have a lot of
lactobacilli but you do have a lot of
these other species
um and and they're incredibly High
diversity and in really contrast to the
rules of ecological systems High
diversity in this case is actually
associated with poorer indicators of
health and we'll go a little into what
that might mean
and then you sort of when you work your
way through the other groups over here
what you start to see is groups of
people whose retro microbiome is really
characterized by dominance of a single
species so over here you have the red
bar indicating that people within this
group have
um a highly dominant presence of
lactobacillus ginseniae
likewise in this group lactobacillus
crispitus
well the hero lactobacillus in ours
and then finally lactobacillus gasseri
so even within lactobacillus dominance
you really have a number of different
lactobism species that are dominant
within that community and this paper
sort of set called these Community State
types and this is something that has
since um really in the last decade been
confirmed across the world so there have
been sequencing studies in multiple
different countries identifying some
subset of these communities so you might
not find all activism species but you do
tend to find broadly either lactobacilli
dominant low diversity communities or
high diversity non-lactive SLI
communities and it's it's pretty
consistent in reproductive age groups so
when you think about this as a bacterial
Community it's really quite independent
of diet and and really human adapted the
other aspect that's that's quite unique
is that it is very
um you don't find these in other animals
so our primates and our cousins do not
have this uh assistance light dominance
in the vaginal bacteria which really
begs the question of how um what are we
gaining from this having this community
be adapted to human health what exactly
are they how are they affecting host
immunity and
um what can you understand about the
biological mechanisms around this so of
course when we think about hormonal
driven adaptation you can start to think
about pregnancy and people have seen
that lactobacilli are strongly
correlated to better pregnancy outcomes
so in this paper
um my fat fight that came out at in 2019
what they did is they sequenced the
communities of people who then
um went on to give birth either pre-term
or defined as less than 36 weeks or at
term and what you see here is that while
you do see some lactobacilli dominance
in the community that gave birth preterm
it's much more enriched in people who
gave birth at turn and they actually did
metagenomics in this community which led
to this fascinating graph where they
were actually able to look at what genes
associated with individual bacterial
species so what you're seeing here is
towards the left is term but towards the
right is pre-term birth and each of
these dots refer to genes within these
bacterial species and then darker the
dot sort of the most significantly so
while they did see that some of the
species in that more diverse cluster we
talked about earlier
um prevotella smithia were associated
with pre-term birth what really
fascinated uh me is that the largest
cluster associated with term books so
giving
um Alberto carrying her pregnancy to
term was lactivism lactobacillus
crispitis again really suggesting an
incredibly strong correlation between
these species of bacteria and the
vaginal tract to pregnancy outcomes
which are really sort of spatially
separate and happening in the uterus
um and these sort of differences the
other important part to know is that the
lactobacillus jensenia gaseri and nurse
clusters are not as strongly cluster um
as strongly correlated with
um
birth that term and this sort of
differentiation between individual
species of lactobacillus
um actually carries through to other
clinical correlates and as an example
um a set of studies coming out of a
cohort in South Africa saw very this was
conducted by the Quan's lab so very
similar communities so in this case they
call them cervical types so you have
cervical type 1 associated with
crossfadis two associated with dominance
of MERS and three and four were sort of
two different groups that had these high
diversity non-lactobacillus dominant
communities and what they were able to
do with this cohort was actually for a
period of years track incidents of HIV
and the results were really quite Stark
so what they saw was that in the group
of people with crispabis dominant
microbiomes they saw not a single
incidence of HIV over three years
um this was not true of people with
inners or people with a high diversity
communities really suggesting that these
um the specific species dominance in the
vaginal practice strongly correlated
with uh resistance to in this case HIV
but another studies show extending this
to other sexually transmitted infections
and sort of as an example the other
correlating here is when you look at
vaginal inflammation again having
crispronous dominant microbial
communities in the vagina is correlated
with less full-inflammatory cytokines
um present in vagina so if we were to
sort of take a pause and put together
everything I've talked to so far
um you could think about vaginal
microbiomes being divided into two
categories you have your lactobacilli
dominant low diversity categories and
you have your lactobacile low high
diversity communities and in this lack
of this lie low high diversity
communities in contrast to what we know
about the intestine this um increase in
diversity is actually strongly
correlated with negative Health outcomes
specifically increased
um acquisition of sexually transmitted
viral infections
um David studies also showing increased
transmission because you look at very
unload within the vaginal tract you see
increased rate of preterm birth as well
as increased basal vaginal inflammation
and um you know there's a lot of sort of
groups that really study uh the
associations between specific bacterial
species to trying to understand how they
drive vaginal inflammation and
potentially increase acquisition of STDs
on the other hand when you look at these
lactobacilli dominant low diversity
communities you really see that the
flavor of lactobacillus species that you
have is also pretty important while
broadly speaking again in this case then
stark contrast to other
microecosystems low diversity is
strongly correlated with health and
resilience but also that the specific
species you have is quite important so
you see over here that lactobacillus
Christ in particular is strongly
associated with healthier outcomes
um and so what happens to the sort of
balance between these two groups of uh
communities and you can start to ask
yourself
um you know if you have one Community do
you always have that how um how
resilient is it and how
um how long does it stay on within a uh
particular person and um to look into
that I have to introduce you to one of
the most common
um really medical syndromes that
afflicts people
um which is called bacterial vaginosis
and it's really sort of a fascinating
Indian mystery um and it has really high
clinical consequences
so on the right what I'm showing you
again is a vaginal
um smear and you might recognize this
from the slide earlier that I showed you
so on the healthy subjects what you see
are these
um epithelial cells surrounded by what
are ground positive rods or lactobacilla
um but when you from like a smear from
someone with bacterial vaginosis which
you'll see instead are gram-negative
cocci that are really overgrowing and
present in the smear and one of the
fascinating things is this balance
between
um ground positive lactobacilli and
brown negative High diversity
communities it's actually a clinical
criteria for diagnosing the because it's
called the new gym criteria
um BB is also incredibly diverse it can
look very different in in different
people and in fact if you take healthy
subjects you would find absence of
lactobacilliity Ravel paper earlier when
we looked at healthy people so you can
actually see non-lactobacilli high
diversity communities present in healthy
people but it is also highly correlated
to for health welcome so understanding
that shift between the presence of these
bacteria and lack of symptoms and
understanding what sort of drives them
symptomatic bacterial vaginosis is
something that is really an open
question in the field
um as I said before BB is associated
with loss of lactobacillight dominance
and increased anaerobic bacteria and it
really remains unclear if it's sexually
transmitted because there are multiple
people who see an increase in incidence
of beauty
um after sex but um but also people who
don't describe that Association so it's
not as very much an open question
um the other so why do we care so much
about about BB right so it's really in
addition to to the symptoms being really
painful and um lower in quality of life
that's a risk multiplier so a single BB
episode can increase risk of multiple
STDs including chlamydia gonorrhea
um it can independently increase your
risk for HIV acquisition along with
having herpes and it's really thought
that there's something that baby does to
the vaginal immune homeostasis because
even if you say treat having herpes and
other sexually transmitted infection
which increases your risk for HIV
um and even upon treatment of herpes
with acycloviria you still have
increased HIV acquisition in people with
ve so there's something sort of
fundamental about the vaginal immune and
homeostasis that's changed in Beauty
um and the really depressing thing about
this is that BB is still treated
um and the same way for the last 70
years which is with antibiotics and the
recurrence rate can be up to 60 in
particular populations so this is
something that not only is devastating
for quality of life but actively
increases your risk for multiple
outcomes I didn't mention here having
baby also increases your risk for
preterm birth
um and and we really don't have good
Solutions
um to help that population of people who
just get procurement BB and I I would
posit that understanding more about the
vaginal homeostasis would really help us
um look at what is driving the the harm
associated with
so given all of this a reasonable
questions asked might be well what can
we do to manipulate the vaginal
micro given that we know what is
associated with health and I can tell
you a little bit about what's been done
in this area as well so in
um 2019 there was a randomized trial of
lactivity which was basically a vaginal
suppository of specific lactobacillus
christopherus communities and they gave
a pretty high Loop some listed over here
for over 10 weeks and
um the results were
positive but with a very small effect
and so what people saw in fact was that
while it did reduce recurrence of BB by
15 if you looked further out for another
10 weeks in less than um this particular
strain was only found in less than 50 of
people so just in the community changes
is even in a simple and small community
is really quite difficult
um and I want to I want to also pause
and say here that um oral-based
Community change so basically taking
probiotics or early to change your
vaginal Community
um really has been shown to not work
this trial was done with a vaginal
suppository which at least introduces
the bacterial community directly to the
miposa but as we can see from this trial
we really do need um to understand more
about what it takes to affect change
there has been a single study of a
non-randomized lateral microbiome
transplant in which they took vaginal
fluid
um from people and transplanted them to
people with recurrent BB this was done
with really just five people and what
you can see from here are in terms of
abundance the doctor blue
um says before bacteria Malachi
gardnerella which is a bacteria strongly
associated with
um bacterial vaginosis and lactobacillus
so what you can see here is with a and b
um people a single dose was sufficient
to increase lactobacillus dominance at
least out to about four months but with
three out of the five people they really
needed repeated dosage and for one of
them even multiple dosages did not seem
to work so we really need to understand
more about what drives Community change
and what what are the what is the
heterogeneous factors between different
people and their microbiomes
um there is the first uh randomized
vaginal transplant um study ongoing
right now in Boston area it's called The
Motif study and it's run by Dr Carolyn
Mitchell and Dr Daquan and um Dr Fatima
Asha and I strongly recommend going to
their website and checking it out if
you're in the area because they are
looking for blog donors as well as child
uh participants and I think the study
will really tell us more about what are
the factors that
um you know is it possible to transplant
a whole Community when you also add
um environmental factors on like a
probiotic suppository this would be
taken nuisance and whatever other
factors of sugars might be in the labad
and hopefully help that Community to
flourish
um and I have really high hope that we
might learn something
from this and I encourage you to go
check out the motive study all right and
so when we think about what it takes for
a vaginal microbiome
um transplant to work we can ask what
does stability look like in the vaginal
microbiome and we have a great way to
look at that which is the accural
menstrual periods so for example here
this is a paper that sampled women
during menstruation for about four
months so the red dots at the bottom of
the graphs
um refer to a menstrual period and what
you see here is abundance of bacteria
and what you see
um so this is a cruspada's dominant
subject and right around these red dots
you see a drop and crispatis and an
increase in in this case streptococcus
however at the end of the menstrual
period crosspadas comes right back and
this is something that we're really
trying to mimic when we think about
Community change and you can see these
in other subjects as well so for example
here you had somebody whose community
did not change at all
um during during menstrual period but
remained crispod is dominant however
when they did undergo a temporary change
between menstrual periods again Chris
bottas was able to come back up
menstrual periods can also be a time of
community shifting so in this case you
this subject had a nurse dominant
community that bounced back after
several months or periods but after the
last one indicated over here underwent a
community change that more diverse lack
of the salai Lost community and in fact
this paper found that inners in general
tended to be a gateway community out of
lactobacilli dominance into loss of
lactobacilli in general so I would um
really positive that we need more of
these kinds of menstrual
um study clinical profiling to be able
to understand
um how lactobacillite communities bounce
back from this natural occurrence and
perturbation and if we understand how
these bacteria are doing that we can
take advantage of that to better
um uh capture Community change
um to be able to push people towards
healthier microbiomes
and what the last really 10 minutes I
want to talk a little bit about what we
know about vaginal antiviral immunity
within the new vaginal mucosa
um and so when you think about the
vaginal mucosa really dominated by
um these bacterials the funding viruses
we do understand less about this and you
think about how the microbiome protects
you from infection
um so if you're a mucosal pathogen you
will encounter the microbiome before you
encounter the eukaryotic host and these
interactions can really influence
infectivity and transmission and for the
most the bacterial pathogens and the
bacterial components of the microbiome
these bacterial bacterial interactions
um are uh between two alike organisms so
broadly a microbiome can be protective
against invading bacterial pathogens
however we might imagine that this looks
quite different for viral pathogens and
one of the things that my lab is really
quite interested in is understanding the
interactions that drive this microbial
microbial
um
communication at the mucosa
but there's also the cells um at the
mucosal surface and being a stratified
squamous epithelia the vaginal micro uh
mucosa also has these small numbers of
immune cells that
um circulate and sort of traffic in and
out of the mucosa and one of the things
we found
um
pretty early on was that you can
actually you don't need a lot of immune
cells to be activated to generate
protection of the mucosa this is work
that was published I'm not going to go
too much into it but we actually found
that giving a bacterial small molecule
that was a total like receptor ligand
that activated less than one percent of
these specialized adaptive immune cells
in this case dendritic cells in the
vaginal mucosa and activated a host of
antiviral genes transcribed within these
cells and that one percent of cells
activating these genes was sufficient to
protect the entire vaginal mucosa
against what genital herpes simplex as
well as zika virus and so this really
speaks to looking Beyond and tractions
with the vaginal epithelial cells but
actually studying how vaginal microbes
might be impacting these really small
immune populations within the mucosa to
better get a sense of how they alter
um immunity and um in the last five
minutes I'm going to tell you one small
story about a vaccine technique that we
hope will really sort of
um lead the way to understand more about
um inducing and activating immune cells
within the mucosa and to do that I'm
going to highlight one particular
antiviral Gene in here that's also a
chemokine in this case this is the
chemokine
cxcl10 which we know from a lot of
previous work can recruit T cells into
into the vaginal mucosa where they can
then become something called tissue
resident T cells where they stay within
the mucosa don't circulate in and out
and provide really lifelong immunity and
one of the reasons to Target these kinds
of cells is that your mucosal immunity
is really quite different from your
circulating immunity so when we think
about how we test for vaccine results
you really look for factors of vaccines
working whether that's antibodies or
activated T cells and circulation and
that may or may not be a good reflection
of mucosal protection and in fact we
know that in the case of herpes there
are multiple vaccines that have induced
really high levels of circulating
antibodies and activated T cells that
still completely fail to protect and so
in light of this
um
first came up with the idea of prime and
full as a vaccine technique and the idea
was to take vaccines that had
um you know succeeded at generating lots
and lots of circulating antibodies and
activated T cells and circulation but
failed at mucosal protection and by
understanding the chemokin cues you
could then rescue them by pulling you
know all of these cells that were
activated in a circulation to the right
glucosa and that's why they call this
sort of prime and Pull and what's great
is that in the last couple of years
we've shown that acute division mucoside
this works really well so you can
um they showed that it was protective
prophylactically against general herpes
and mice by generating local memory T
cells and since then they've been two
studies coming out showing that you can
also protect therapeutically so actually
prevent or reduce herpes
um uh Varian replication in individuals
that already have argument it's an
example of this we use the guinea pig to
study this so this is a
um uh image of the guinea pig mucosa and
the Red Green Dots here are reflective
of virus specific CDT cells and what I
want you to see here is here's your
vaccine vaccinated guinea pig that has
very few T cells but just application of
a
uh pull compound you can increase T Cell
density in the vaginal mucosal where
they need to protect against invading
viruses and you can also see these these
guinea pigs develop
um herpetic ulcers very similar to what
we see in people and you really see that
here you're comparing between the Green
vaccine and the arm and the purple
vaccine and full arm you saw far fewer
lesions in herpetic ulcers and guinea
pigs that got the prime and full vaccine
and what um we were able to show is that
we could use this really cheap small
molecule which actually is also an
antibiotic so we found that Amino
glycoside antibiotics activated
dendritic cells in the vaginal mucosa to
really induce antiviral immunity and
just application of this
neomycin antibiotic protected mice
prophylactically against
um acute infection equivalent to chemo
pain and one of the reasons this is
exciting is really that um chemokine and
or protein really can be expensive and
have and labile and require a cold chain
but this is you know really a
off-the-shelf small molecule that would
be pretty easy to apply
um topically as a full agent that really
extends this technique into this vaccine
technique into something that can be
um you know carried out pretty easily
but how does this then relate back to
the microbiome so I would actually posit
that while it's important to look at the
members of these communities in here
that are driving inflammation equally
that there are these lactobacilli
dominant populations that are associated
with increased antiviral immunity and
you could start to think about what
other small molecules are being secreted
by these communities over here that
might affect host immunity
um in ways that we um really just
haven't found out yet
and so if you want to put this together
on the concept of how the vaginal
microbiome might be an affecting
antiviral Immunity on this side you have
a very on the right side of this picture
you have a very diverse High diversity
low lactobacilliant microbiome that
induces lots of inflammatory cytokines
and we still don't understand how these
inflammatory cytokines Drive increase of
susceptibility to infections um it's a
little bit easier with HIV where you
could say oh they actually end up
calling more T cells and that serves as
a host for more virus but that doesn't
quite explain the increase
susceptibility to other STDs including
chlamydia gonorrhea and herpes
um conversely we see with these low
diversity vaginal microbiomes we might
imagine that they are actually secreting
things that are actively alter the
immune environment within the vaginal
mucosa and that investigating this
um these communities could really see
serve as a a potent greater mind for
novel immunomodulators and that in fact
in the last minute is something that my
lab is working pretty heavily on so
we've been kind of identifying ways that
the microbiome influences the host
immune response posed by both by mining
these lactobacilli or novel compounds
and also by trying to really make
artificial sort of mouse models that are
colonized with human lactivism as I told
you lactobus layer unique to people just
sort of begin to understand how they
affect host immunity most of our best
immunological tools are really built in
mind so we need to find a way to get
these bacteria to stay within the
massagina so we can understand how they
influence those immune responses so
that's something that we're actively
working on within the lab right now
and with that I'd like to take a moment
and thank members of my lab I wasn't
able to talk about their work today but
we have several exciting projects on
these interactions and we think we've
identified a novel immunomodulator that
I hope to tell you more about later
um and with that I hope you enjoyed the
talk